we've given you code for the beginnings
of a weather provider class within the
data package that extends content
provider one of the tools that Android
provides to help write a content
provider is a uri matter which we are
going to write shortly filling out a uri
matter is the third step in building our
content provider content providers
implement functionality based upon you
our eyes passed to them our content
provider will implement four types of
your eyes each one of these your eyes
will be used to execute different types
of operations against the underlying
SQLite databases for ease of
implementation content providers
typically tie each you are i type
internally to an integer constant these
integer constants have already been
added to the provided weather provider
class Android provides a URI mattrick
class to help match incoming your eyes
to the content provider integer
constants this is important because we
need to have a way of knowing which type
of URI is passed into our content
providers so we can perform the
requested operation once we have the
integer constants we can easily use them
in switch statements URI match our
provides for an expression syntax to
match various you are is that works a
bit like regular expressions hash
symbols will match a number and an
asterisk will match any string here are
some examples